[Music] what up people we are at the final
episodes of Scott Pilgrim takes off John
Hario I am not ready to let go G man how are you
I am I'm yeah I'm going to miss it I'm going to
miss it decided decided In This Moment oh good
guys leave a like thank you to everyone who's
been here for this journey with us also big
thank you to all who have joined us over at
our patreon page uh for Scott pogm take us off we
also cover several things over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included that
is where you can catch the full length R and
watch along where you sync it with your own
copy all righty guys let's see what's going
on and also thank you to preer for helping
us set down these highlights let's get to
[Music] it what do we
got oh homeboy travel through time
and space what time travel oh it's a
Scott Pilgrim Focus episode the Scott
overse excuse me is it a multiversal
Scott is that what we're going to get like maybe
he planned it but he didn't plan it what even is
any of whoa nice what is becoming of him oh who
are you show why you're the greatest Warrior
Scott The Last of Us this is my
exact thought it's the wrecked
set where are we Toronto Canada is he
the narrator the future oh who John
your Scott Pilgrim 37 years old still
awesome I Am Legend Scott two Scott two
Pilgrim so we hell happened in Canada yeah
might even make it to 40 if we're lucky it
is Will Forte are we rich and famous do we
win a lot of cool fights we do okay the fact
that we can grow a beard alone alone somebody
appreciates it it's not that far in the future I
know said literally somebody making the noise my
mouth Whoa We Live Here No way here let me show
you our house did you actually purchase it or is
it stolen or is cyber Punk Canada just still so
polite and affable that you could just kind
of walk up and claim it Oh What a Beautiful
home this looks like Lucas Le home but that's in
Canada this is in Canada this is in Canada the
league of evil xes that takes me back whatever
happened with that no let me break it down for
you fighting those xes was the biggest mistake of
our entire life oh because we lost no because we
won yeah buddy so this is like a sequel kind of
yeah a requel you have virtual reality Game Boy
we have it all the future's more futuristic
than they originally predicted future is more
futuristic Cod Secrets the
P oh my God somebody in this life is going
to build themselves A Classic Game Boy vault
door welcome to the VR chamber virtual guy
give this one is oh I did miss you Scott
memories virtual guy me and Ramona Ramona
and I that's that one guy I know him and
that guy they don't look so tough that guy
just skateboarded to his death God they're
Chumps it's movie yeah so Ramona dated a
robot that's Progressive no no she dated
the twins they're humans yes another red
flag pal I don't see any flag and it's all
red she's like Princess Leia oh we get married
this is really sweet actually what goes wrong
minions I love it oh Universal Studios yeah
this is a really nice project man oh is that
that that's not part of it anymore ignore
that one I I told him to take that out next
screen divorce now this one looks like it's in a
completely different style it's the exact same if
not better no it's definitely worse whoever did
this is bad at art oh that's the end of it yep
technically we're separated after the honeymoon
12 13 odd years later we must have had some good
times oh sure but those aren't in the simulation
so he's just completely and utterly alone Scott
Pilgrim versus the world I'm talking about
my new band Popp and twinby the members are
me and the twins I told you about the twins
though right you're in the league you said we
defeated them oh yeah but after they respond
at home I guess they learn their lesson or
[Music] whatever oh my God [Music] love that
it's half in Japanese this is really
capturing this kind of music videos
Man loving
you it's a Bop right over a 100 views over
a 100 how did he gain all the success says
hey why is all of old Wallace's old stuff in our
garage where's Wallace now when I said our house
you thought I meant me and you knock knock you
boys want some ice Silver Fox Wallace SCS yikes
nobody mentioned Sonic the Hedgehog it's 39
all it's a call back to Sonics to the first
episode yeah how can old Wallace affords such a
big house I can afford it it's kind of a sugar
daddy situation sugar oh hey bird he's going
to find out one way or another all right I I
didn't want to do this so soon but he's right
what what are we gay Wallace's husband works
at Nintendo where they make the video games get
every game for free yes he doesn't that's not true
it's true they get every game for free I thought
you said it was a sugar daddy I'm really really
really happy for you oh please you're seeding
with jealousy get your own husband who is your
hubby this was your idea I'm sorry yeah when me
and Ramona were having problems you said too bad
I don't have a time machine so I can go back
and stop myself from dating her in the first
place oh no oh no how the hell did you get a time
machine in the first place that technology hasn't
even been invented yet oh one of the twins do
you think time travel is possible hm [Music]
he's reti but get the robot out of retirement
he would experience the entire duration of his
existence simultaneously whoa which would mean in
theory at least sure yeah time travel kid stuff
easy here's a simple pie chart for you I took you
away from Ramona on purpose see I used to have a
heart it was right here it's gone because she tore
it out you can tell me what you did wrong and I
can go back and do a better job you immediately
assume I messed up yep I do the dishes I walk
the cats I make the spaghetti I won't take you
back to the past until I know for a fact that
you won't date Ramona Flowers because she's the
one who's bad news not us oh boy a jeez it's never
good when your future self comes to you remember
how you were after NV Adams dumped you it's like
that time 10 I like how this is a pure reflection
of Scott it's whole season I like it's not I like
this idea I like this idea a lot yeah didn't I see
you at the rocket back at our show in the past did
you happen to get any of that on video you record
video of everything he's going to see his entire
life everything everything all at once oh and he
could experience via VR nice peace [Music] nuts
whoa yes was he connected to the past there yeah
may I guess so maybe the Scott who's been the
robot who's been watching has just been Scott
yeah just like Scott keeping an eye on all this
stuff and peering in throughout the season and
so old Scott also wrote the script and gave it
to Young Neil interesting but the script is about
him winning Ramona's heart age don't ask she can't
be roughly 30 to 40 I love how she actually
looks young still yeah oh no stop we come in
peace the tea I heard about old used idiotic
time travel plan convincing himself to stop
being obsessed with me has he met himself
that's why I came up with a backup plan
he has met himself now one of your dumb
Friends wrote A Memoir Scott and Ramona
and me my precious big life as Scott
Pilgrim's best pal my old [Laughter]
young oh yeah if old Scott was going to erase
everything I wanted there to be some way for
you to discover our story a I sent it back in
time you have a time machine too too they're
made out of parts from an old DeLorean when I
hit 88 M hour I travel through time oh my God
except Scott doesn't read books but I thought
of that so I moved some scenes around combined
a few characters and before I knew it oh oh
like a real biopic so young Neil did write
it that's crazy in a way in a sense yeah the
plan may have been misguided I just I had to
try he's the love of My Life the movie fell
apart careers ended that's not the story I
saw it's the friends we made along the way it's
the closure you got with all your evil exes so
yeah man he was watching the Ramona I left
she was looking for me looking for answers
never giving up like that famous detective
Columbo I was going to say detective Pikachu
yes you're Rona sounds pretty cool so cool
I love the music in this show it's very
transportive into the purse 88
mph here we go but what is it in
kilometers Trail and everything hey baby miss
me how's work Wallace you do have a heart so
that's why you're steaming wait is future me
here hey well hi uh I got to get a picture of
[Applause] this so funny just P right out
right oh thanks knives so fun I met someone
so I've gathered I'm really sorry and maybe this
isn't the best time to have this realization but
I probably shouldn't have been dating you in
the first place oh wow Scott I'm glad you're
alive but I'm also glad you died gave me a
lot of space to reflect and grow so thanks a
[Music] yeah what what what is it metaphorical
nope what
the what the [__] what if I still have
to fight your exes how much did you see
on that futuristic VR thingy I'm pretty much
caught up then you know the game is changed
but the players are the same Ramona could
fight them with her with him yeah they can
fight them together somewhere you could
find all the exes gathered together at
the same time to celebrate musical
theater yes the show precious little
musical this is such a fascinating
culmination all seven evil xes in
person
Dizzle they got him by still yeah and
he's still got his ulterior motives
whoa not bad not bad rcta
whoa turkey leg oh my God
could be plant- paste it could be a toe furky leg
true then it's time for the big finale
let's go roll credits I'm excited yeah me
too I we've seen these credits multiple
times yeah I still have not caught the
narrator wow the orchestra Tunes oh my God
St okay now double that and we done oh my
God oh my God your bows are going to explode out
your stomach oh come on evil X number three Todd
Ingram right oh he's got to go in different order
vegan let's fight me fight you over Ramona and
I'm vegan no longer I had a cheese plate for
breakfast lunch and dinner today whoa you owe
me a new tub of butter popcorn you are wal's
roommate tell me everything where was he born
what is his middle name does he have a favorite
vegetable still a vegan left in there somewhere
I'm not interested in Kurds and way there were
Sparks there's no such thing not even fire
[Laughter] Sparks God do not be throwing
hands at me right now this is the biggest
night of my career I shouldn't even be wasting
my voice on you so really doing right here in
the lobby yeah you're the freaking star you
didn't create a force field preventing me and
Ramona from kissing did you that evil villain
stuff is behind me I've got Jewels now the hell
is going on Lucas Lee also cleared I don't know
let me tell you about Broadway bad boy Matthew
P whoa do either of you know anything about this
force field thingy and would either of you like
to fight about it nope come on let's go watch a
stupid musical about a stupid guy is bored as a
foot with a mouth like the hand with a mouth
lo I know it was the ex's who made it Scott
Pilgrim's precious little musical we're not
here to fight our robot says we're all bros
in the future so later bro we've ruled out
all my exes no fights no kissing this finale
sucks n it'll get better don't worry whoa God
there's like a sea mine up there some hot fuzz
[__] very cinematic shot yeah damn one
like the subtle like fishing Scott Pilgrim
so you got the girl you going to kiss her
or what kiss her kiss her all support Jesus
I'm Scott Pilgrim I know shut up
I had that dream again I didn't
care the first time you told me I care even less
now evil
evil wow Scot you seem so upset this such a great
medley bread makes you fat bread makes you fat
what's wrong with that yeah oh yeah had a [Music]
plan whoa what is are they all getting Su into the
future the world versus Scott Pilgrim
attack still not cool Goose enough
oh lens but old no even older oh mental health and
wellbe unknown 47 years old how you doing love the
white hair whoa he's so buff I explicitly told you
to stay away from Ramona but did you listen no wow
this show is so cool yeah man got me twice with
this gotten Ramona Must Be Love hey give us a
kiss you two let's see those Sparks oh it was
you it was the even older one I had a backup
plan I guess it was Nano machines in your drinks
of course you'll find the AK Fields they generate
to be quite impenetrable you son of a [__] anti
field [Music] yes so why are you here fighting us
because winning didn't change anything we still
end up marrying Ramona oh your stupid friends must
team up at some point in my new past and figure
out how to dissolve the anti-k fields oh wow
I respect the work you've put into this villain
plot but I have my own villain plot going on we've
got no beef with you what if I have a beef with
you oh let's go it looks cool man wow he's just
gotra Powers somehow Scott Pilgrim returned after
you left the future and after old Wallace kicked
me out I began my training yeah 10 years I did
nothing but study all of your skills your strength
your weaknesses because there's only one way to
end that me versus the world yeah Scot versus
everyone oo this is a true
anime yeah h plus 10 against
Elders oo damn no anti-p punch fields on
those damn
come on even older Scot and
someh just kind of rooting
for you oh Rona are you okay wow this is a turn of
events oh what we got oh yes oh
cool it's time to to down Chow
Down awesome
wow love
yes whoa oh my God it's kind of
like that Hunter Hunter we just
watched level that's great extra powerups
O Let's Go skater die
ouch she still got the tattoo
I love they took the time for
that this isn't even my final form look at the
punch it's like anime in the
best Nintendo fighting games
Gordon damn so weird to almost be rooing for
Gordon hey no there's no way there could be
the end of it Scot he's got to do
this alone oh but he's got Ramona
oh god let's hit them together
wait huh yes of course
[Music] ah nice you need to let me live my
life if I do you'll end up where I ended up
alone for 10 years that was your choice so
extreme yeah you oh my god what if what if
he's right he's you you think I want to
become that guy I won't oh my God yeah
whoa future Ramona yeah or even more future Ramona
10 years then Wallace tells me you're training to
go back in time and fight yourself a lot of people
we hit one rough patch and you go completely
insane oh no fighting all of these people yeah and
uh robot when you could have been fighting for us
this SC in them yep are you saying that we weren't
over are you saying that you still loved me at the
time yes oh so what about me you're telling me
I should just skate on call it another failed
experiment no no run run away from the thing that
you love oh oh my God the show's giving me exactly
the thing I complained about two episodes ago
yes yeah oh my God always skating away I'm done
running huh such a great movie line you yes I
Choose You A selflove Ramona in the power of
selflove hug yourself Scott super Ramona
just like super the hedgehog three I mean
three kick his ass super Ramona no no
it's never too late to clean up a mess
but I will send him home so he can get started
oh well this is great not the me who left him
and the me who just met him we're the
same I see that now it's all the same
who yes yes yes
[Music] [__] hey Sparks because I'll
have a lot of trouble saying it later
let me say it now I love you Scott a but
what I've done in the past doesn't have to
Define me it's all your fault help me keep
remembering that okay super Rona yes the
Rona a Sparks a he's flexing is there any
way you would take the Empire back just let
me keep my show and the rest of it is yours
of course everyone gets what they want this
was his ultimate plan L yeah just to make
some [Laughter] friends we 2 okay yeah
[Music] hey yeah
knives epilog are they going to perform for Envy
or do they write a song for
Envy stun actress yes she black widow or she a
star no we need physical media make out without
you hey you got a job there nice a oh my
God he's made for this Superstar Barista
Lucas Lee At Your Service whatever uh whatever
yeah whatever damn so annoying but the tips are
good and I do get to look at his butt all
day that's America's ass I'm spending the
money I got for starring as myself in this
major Canadian motion picture that never got
made have to make her Nintendo must be the
die one more ASMR you think she's going to
have a smile this time it's a smiley face hair
do certainly feeling lighter smile hey feeling
[Music]
free nothing cooler than her guitar nothing
cooler nothing feels cooler there is no oh
Doug surewood there's nothing there's no
greater discrepancy between what feels
cool and what looks cool than air guitar oh
stepen root was the Nan machines time for
the real game to begin the goose is loose
honk HCK teas for the second season testal
combat yeah they played this song
uh in the first episode oh okay
yeah dude all right so okay let's immediately
rank it is it better than uh is it better than the
movie come on book process confident answer right
now without go this has at least more breathing
room to to maybe uh create a different sort of
more nuanced emotional impact w wow recency bias
wow I mean the nothing beats the movie screw this
I don't like art at all unless Edgar Wright made
it that means my pool of art is precious limited
God you know what they should do they should
go to reject Nation shop.com that would help me
decide get some real rejects apparel there that's
a great way to support the channel look as fly as
everyone in the show you get shirts like this RR
shirt that I'm wearing and it's my favorite way
you can support the channel it's John's favorite
way you can support the channel it's your favorite
way to support the channel know you don't know yet
but look at all these shirts oh my God involved
ourselves in all these cre for every different
day of like half the month I know exactly which
shirt is flashing on screen on which point to I
love that one the most we I don't even I might
have even talked longer than necessary and we're
just now we're having to repeat shirts and we run
out of shirts to flash let that start over again
yeah look at them shirts oh look at these shirts
then to start showing like thumbnails videos you
should watch keep going through and through and
through and through oh man yeah that was fun that
was great I think those last two episodes it was
funny cuz like the pen the Penultimate for us but
not the real penultimate penultimate 2 I found
myself craving a little bit more development for
Ramona since the focus was on her yeah and it's
a fun little flipper a great inverse of things
where you find out that it's been from Ramona
and Scott's perspective this entire time the
character you spent the most time with is Ramona
however it has also still been from SC perspective
yeah which is really cool yeah it's a great way
to uh make you go see we didn't go we we didn't
we fully pissed that certain crowd off they just
needed to not Rage Quit long enough to get here
to see it they just need to get her to the end um
but the the author behind this I don't know any of
the behind the scenes information on it but the
the telling of this is great because I I really
feel like it captured the heart underneath the
caricature of everyone here and like especially
by the time you get to the end it it really seemed
like it had a a softer sympathetic approach you
can feel the writer going you know I like these
guys and I want to see a little bit more of the
love underneath everyone and how at the end
of the day all these people who have become
obsessive freaks over Ramona H they're all broken
individuals yeah and this is is a significant
motivator for various aspects of their lives that
they might not be able to admit not everyone got
like the most development I would say you know
like the twins didn't really get development and
I mean it's a it's a nice subversion but yeah
it's like they don't get really get a fight or
anything like that and and when they do show
up it's almost always kind of just facilitate
something and I thought like while they had a in
the live action movie at least uh I while I liked
their sequence with the music battle the battle
of the bands uh it's still they were still like
the least interesting characters to me because
they didn't really get character yeah they didn't
really speak much you know so like their fight is
the most interesting thing about them but they do
get them a very important plot Point via creation
of the robot yeah and I mean the Nano like they're
they're the the the accompli and the like R&D
department for so many of the minations that that
affect Scott and Ramona throughout those yeah th%
man I mean I thought the show was very beautiful
and it it's an inspiration of like 80s and 90s
video games uh and Anime and and it really feels
like an embodiment all of it it it doesn't just
feel like it's something that is on the surface
level paying homage there's something that speaks
from a genuine part again it's the word that keeps
coming to mind is you can feel the soul behind it
not just notes of things they wanted to attempt it
it feels naturally from within that is coming out
when I say the word expressive I'm not using that
word lightly because it really does feel like an
expression of Soul here yeah it's super evocative
like it it has so much kind of emot emotional
richness to it and that sometimes in small you
know little ways that are kind of precious and
then in other times it's in big overflowing
ways that are very sort of uh all-encompassing or
very like relatable in a in a grander way and uh
and yeah like this while you don't spend a lot of
time with Ramona and Scott it's still an epic Love
Story 100% because you feel the you you feel I car
way more about this love story than I did in the
movie yeah yeah I would agree and you feel it kind
of from both their perspectives and I like that it
lets you sit in the bitter sweetness that love can
be because I mean there's so much like the rush of
Love uh you know can can often come with that sort
of like I don't know it's a different kind of Rush
it's almost like the rush of falling uh literally
when you know that love is threatened or that love
is called into question in any way shape or form
and and you know there's so much about uncertainty
and this culminates in a way where it's like don't
let your you know fear of the f future based on
the past you know wreck your present almost like
I thought the way that it wo it's like we've seen
this in things before and and even recently
especially with like the older version coming
and finding the young version and it's like kind
of wondrous or fun at first and then it turns out
dark but I thought this was a particularly nice
Lightyear yeah Lightyear uh uh flash uh you know
various it's a Trope that that is a well-worn
Sci-Fi thing that's a passion the Christ to is
about definitely I'm like Jesus listen maybe we
shouldn't get on the cross maybe we should just
deck Judas right there you know take those pieces
of silver start a church of our own you know if I
just embrace the socio and economic essentially
with the Last Temptation Of Crisis oh reaction
ain't never seen it that isn't Jesus coming back
isn't isn't it Willie defo is uh my man is my man
jez yeah yeah I want to see it I want to see oh
my God I should make Willi the fo Scott Pilgrim
he would be a great older Scott Pilgrim if they
ever made another liveaction movie I think that'd
be really funny if they did that but uh yeah we've
seen this thing of of of the older self coming
back and it being a grim cautionary Tale But I I
really like the way that they complemented that
by bringing Ramona's in as well and then giving
the greatest payoff in a sense to her in that
moment complemented everything that came before
and especially as she is you know like so much
of the story is instead of it yeah being Scott
sort of learning to uh not be insecure about all
these evil exes it's more about Ramona learning
to let go of all these people that she pushed
away because of yeah her own uh fear like you know
sabotaging for fear of of this thing failing you
know self- sabotage yeah it's a story of self-love
as well yeah self forgiveness you know yeah and
and and I did feel for them wanting to wanting
to make the love work mhm there's a bit of an
Eternal Sunshine vibe to it yeah cuz it is that
thing of like well you know we're going to spend
the time together but ultimately it's going to
wind up in tragedy and maybe it's just better to
never have to deal with that and it's also kind
of like the time machine it's that thing of like
if you the the more you try and avoid something
the more you're going to bring it about so why
not just live in the moment but it's still an arc
for Scott too you know like seeing who he is in
the future like it it goes past the movie yeah
and like it doesn't I thought maybe they were
going to go extremely meta where you see where
where Scott's look the alternate version is I
feel like the implication is for future Scott
older Scott is here's what happened after the
movie that's kind of like the the implication yeah
right um and they you see that they didn't have a
happily ever after but they could have just made
it work if he matured yeah but he like jumped ship
too early instead of working through it you know
yeah and and he just became an obsess of Escape
of uh individual too like he never truly grew up
and he never fully realized yeah what the real
thing to blame was yeah so I think uh they both
get like a character Arc and it shows that for
the relationship to work they both have to work
on each other's individual things yeah and not
it's not just a story about them realizing like
oh I need to learn one thing about myself like
it goes deeper than that and again it doesn't
feel like pretentiously deep it because the
movie the show still keeps it extremely Whimsical
extremely vibrant uh everything is like ramped to
an 11 here and uh and and I thought that it was
also very tender and nuanced I was I was really
impressed with this show man it gave us something
in very very different and it it took a tad bit
of readjusting and a little bit to see where it
goes but I also get why this is a bin show as
well yeah this actually feels like appropriately B
this one of those shows that could work as either
but I actually think it's better as a binge the
well-roundedness of the story I think Will Shine
especially bright if you binge it but I do think
that remarkably especially for the the to be on
the platform that streamlined and created the the
structure you know the literal structure of shows
that bolsters this binge format you know this is
an example of of something that's not just I make
sure it's got a gripping opening and a gripping
Cliffhanger it's like these actually function well
as pieces they feel like issues out of a greater
like compendium and yeah like they do absolutely
work on their own but as you know we kind of
talked about on the last one after episode six
like the totality I think yeah Will Shine really
really bright as uh just one whole go yeah I like
Ramona Flowers way more here than I do in the film
as an honest take and I like Scott more yeah yeah
it's kind of weird because Scott's not in it as
much but I I do like Scott and Ramona more yeah
and I think again if you've seen the movie I think
that balances out nicely because we've spent work
as a good companion yeah like it's funny like the
characters are well written and well drawn in a
way that makes it so that yeah they compliment and
then I think just you know the the other thing too
is like it's really nice that all these actors are
also really solid for the voice acting they need
from this yeah uh cuz not everybody translates
um and and yeah there's something about I think
the fact that you know we know Michael Sarah so
many of us have seen the movie so we've spent
the time with him and then the first episode I
think giving you so much familiar I never felt
like he was too far away even when I didn't know
that he was like watching over things with the
robot and yeah like Ramona is a solid character
and it's like while you know in the movie both
their flaws are also represented like this is yeah
it's like you can see her involvement in all this
and it just I don't know it just seemed you you
you could see her her involvement in spinning the
web that we're dealing with right now or at least
yeah but but but also how really quick I mean for
how how young Scott got Ramona to realize that
the older Ramona to realize that hey you know
the the Journey of of Scott being taken out of the
equation and and losing to the X instead actually
LED Ramona down a path that was better for her
like the healing process that she went through
and everything so inadvertently by Tak him out it
actually it made things better for everybody yeah
it made things better for literally everybody
yeah except for older Scott but you know it's a
great subversion cuz because you you don't in any
way miss out on the fights and the action which
is fun and and then the dynamic flips around and
you sort of find what else these people have to
fight for and like yeah there are confrontations
but yeah I just think that's like a such a nice
rich like it would work without the movie and
I think it's a really nice play off the movie
because yeah instead of guy fting to a prove his
adequacy to and wi the heart of girl yeah this
is just such a more qual it's like it's a very
appropriate thing to do for the here and now and
people winge every time you make something from
a female perspective that has a man's name in the
title but you know it's her story in so many ways
and uh and yeah it's absolutely a just a lovely
thing they chose to do yeah I think it's really
cool that they made something that I I think the
cell on it I think that's probably the problem
with the marketing is the cell makes you think
you're just going to watch like an anime version
of the movie yeah and they don't re I mean they
want to leave you surprised which is also like
the great thing about it um however I I don't
know I feel like maybe there was there could have
been like a quarter maybe not a middle ground but
like a quarter leaning into that we're really
going to do something very different you know
and take it a very different different direction
sure without spoiling it I don't really know I'm
not a mark I'm not good at marketing so I don't
really know what the [__] it would be however
uh yeah like I think it's a great I think if you
watch the movie and then you watch this they work
perfectly together because and I think this works
better if you see the movie yeah 100% you just you
there's there's a lot more yeah it'll be a fuller
context like I think this is super rich on its own
but yeah there will be a much Fuller context and
I and too I don't know it's one of those things
where they made all these changes but I don't feel
like it in any way betrays any of these characters
and it's nice to see these cartoons take on you
know in the liveaction movie they are certainly
cartoons and then get a character like Lucas Lee
or or any of them you know really but you know
to give them flesh and flavor and heal certain
things Beyond just the thing that makes them
an evil ex like all that stuff is fun but we find
fun in other parts of them and in ways in which we
don't need to keep them broken in these specific
ways and I think that's just a nice maturity of
of characterization yeah and just yeah his whole
like that that one thing Brian leali said about
like approaching this as like a sort of reflection
on as a means of making it its own unique thing
I think is a beautifully rendered Approach at
least by this final product yeah I thought it was
amazing man yeah this is really terrific I thought
it was really amazing beautiful animation all the
way through shot like everything felt handrawn
uh even if it isn't it felt handdrawn every shot
felt incredibly selective everything felt like it
hadp tender love and care you know every element
felt this you know just feels like Living Art you
know the way you say the the kind of compliments
you would give across the spiderverse I would say
they keep that consistent here for every minute
of every one of these episodes yeah it has that or
or it almost has like spiderverse has it and even
different sort of kind of thing but everything
everywhere all at once or or just things that have
this like mad cap quality and they're throwing
like so much at you yet they also have such a Keen
Eye and a compassionate eye towards just emotion
and character and and nuance and things like that
and so yeah you feel like you just took in this
semi overwhelming thing that has so much in it
and yet somehow despite all the potential that
a spiderverse or everything ever or this present
this somehow feels like a definitive version well
it's also so self-aware the way how they they keep
it modern day but they imagine it in the way of
like how would someone in the ' 80s or 90s devise
this plot yeah you know but by keeping him like I
love when he goes to the Future and it's like not
that far in the future but everything is like
a dystopia um [__] like older Scott dystopia
yeah an older Scott is is like so old even though
he's just 37 years oldt but they play it like that
that classic thing that you would see in like '
80s like Wallace is just gray yeah exactly same
gray hair yeah like that's exactly like how
these 80s movies would do somebody make their
hair gray and now they're older and now it's just
10 years from now but they're so much older yeah
yeah totally and just like I don't know the way
it incorporates all it's like it has specific pop
culture references but yeah the way it amalgamates
just so much uh yeah of like retro futurism and
and in in fun silly ways you know there's so much
here it's exciting had punch I love the original
music that they had throughout as well you know
normally with Scott Pilgrim you kind of think yeah
like they have the music that is created within
it for like the characters using it but I'm just
talking about like the when scenes are happening
and you got a bit of that yeah um like eight bit
chip tune kind of yeah yeah it's a good way to put
it it's a good way to put it um overall man I'm
like a I'm like a I don't know I I don't know what
I would really criticize about it I thought it was
pretty near perfect for what they set out to do
honestly yeah yeah absolutely I agree 99999999
yeah just give it a just give it a 10 just go
for it yeah yeah John go for it all right I'll
give it 11 thanks John you're welcome it's an
extra point for the both of us really good yeah
anytime all righty guys well what did you think of
Scott Pilgrim takes off do you prefer it over the
movie do you uh put it on the equal measure what
do you rate the show as a total experience leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like and hey let's send this with
a pandemic Jones pic PJ my friend it's been
a while since we've heard from you my buddy
um but I imagine right now that you are probably
in a Multiverse and exploring alternate versions
of yourselves and one of them is someone who
does create a pandemic himself and is an evil
mastermind because his heart was broken or
and then you see another Universe where hey
uh he is just a reality show chef and he uses
his clout to get laid and Skip lines at movie
theaters and then we go to another Universe of
pandemic Jones where he is a woman the hottest
woman on earth and you use that to skip lines
at movie theaters the there it's always at the
movies no matter what universe there's another
pic Jones and a universe full of where everyone
are are their they their Cricket people they're
just walking crickets and what did they do they
go to the movies and at a theater you could jamack
thousands in one Auditorium so that's why ticket
industry is booming so often times the weight
line is atrocious and complex yes and you're
always hearing crickets but that's good because
that means the Crickets are like in the movie are
relaxed and enjoying it totally and if you want
the best scene in the house you are the president
of cricket planet and pandemic Jones is skipping
lines yes using a secret service to get past
security and get through the crowd of crickets in
order to watch movies that uh are essentially our
films just crickets Bug's Life Bug's Life is
a very it's a very serious drama there exact
same film but a horror it's Terri they have to
deal with [__] oper it's a play on real world
history on that planet and they like don't profile
us we're not grasshoppers it's not the same it's
not the same and uh yeah no I I I Feel You Man
The Cricket planet is rough so uh surprisingly
it's one of the more Grim realities I'm sorry you
never guess it but dude um either way uh you are
someone with a lot of prestige and admired on
every planet you go to but out of any democracy
to be a part of reject Nation admires you the
most so much love to you thank you for being
part of our page and supporting us for so long
and uh chirp chirp my friend chirp [Music] chirp